hello everybody welcome to period
everyone's favorite channel your family
yes Channel everybody take your family
sit down and relax and let's have some
fun cuz that's what we do here fun for
your don't say it
neighbor what is wrong with me today
we're reviewing comedy cemetery that's
right
that's where jokes go to die ready to
get it names you are get launched
through going through the last window
and everything die look ninja techniques
teeny huh that's so smart dude police be
like I hate everything about this
fortnight funnies more like fortnight
funnies this is just making me sad me
master Jimmy Fallon okay that's where
meme goes to die Jimmy Fallon if he
moves goes to die on me review well
they're pretty much cremated at Jimmy
Fallon
Ron hold on are those shoes on sale
Daniel Radcliffe reacts to Harry Potter
memes ah blessed
can we get Daniel Radcliffe toes meme
review that would be epic everyone tweet
Daniel Radcliffe right now I bet you
he's gonna be so surprised I can't wait
to look at his face
this image never dies on Facebook and
Twitter let's bury it here it's just one
of those memes that they just live
forever it's too goddamn funny people
just can't have enough of it I never
thought I'd actually see one outside of
this subreddit had your lunch wife
husband had your lunch wife I am asking
you I'm asking you you copy me you copy
me let's go shopping
yes I had my lunch we accidentally
amputated your genitals
WTF ma'am you need to calm down
I need a baptism every time I review one
of these memes cuz goddamnit
trooloolololol right trollolol on what
the whiteboard when the teacher asked
who did it
hold the troll face in front of your
face and say problem do it guys if this
video gets 5,000 likes I will do the
troll face I love the art as well how to
troll like a boss epic style this is an
awful I feel sick I feel disgusted why
is it so terrible is this how it is how
people pursue it perceive meme review
it's like I get it now
I'm so sorry I didn't know okay happy
10th birthday son here's a rant now go
into the wound and find some strangers
and don't come back until you explore
the entire continent this is basically
the plot to put him on my victim gosh I
never actually seen this one thanks for
explaining the joke fit well I wouldn't
have gone in I have an even smaller
wireless device that gives me access to
thousands of books and movies it's a
library card it's a library card oh I
know I know a joke that needs to be on
the comedy cemetery it's is this one
remember when teachers stayed in school
that will never have a calculator in my
pockets teachers you were wrong teachers
dumbass teachers and knowing orange is
still making videos is that true burps
and farts and kazoos and pantless pants
oh god I've actually have a stage four
cancer now
imagine if fred was still making videos
yeah
imagine if
still here why am I still here goddamnit
have you not made enough money uh yeah
no I want to buy a house in Japan okay
guys please by tomorrow so I can leave
oh god they're still doing it huh
all right well props to them you know
it's raywilliamjohnson still up me that
would be so good what happened to him
five months ago my life is dope and I do
dope [ __ ] my life is dope and I do dope
[ __ ]
my life is dope and I do dope [ __ ] my
life is my life is my life is my life if
my life is so but I don't know [ __ ]
my life is dope and I do dope [ __ ] my
life is dull but I do
don't [ __ ] my life is my life is my life
is my life okay so moving on everybody
let's I think the goal of this video is
to move forward and never look goddamn
it look forward and never look back
that's the idea you are soon my gender
happy Mother's Day
sorry I forgot you're a Democrat us
gamer right I died what do you do wait
for you to respawn we're done she's the
one oh my god if only I could find the
gamer girlfriend here's how you know if
your if your girl's legit hit him with
that what's up Q T and the PI if they go
what just smack her in the face I'm just
kidding if she if she goes now much
teehee you got to hit that push you know
you got to hit it a new low for our
funny
this isn't our funny Oh mr. broccoli my
mother says I should eat you well Timmy
you shouldn't listen to her that
actually made me like I hate myself I'm
part of the problem
Oh God let's give Mimi existential
thoughts I don't know if I can do this
anymore I feel sick I feel sick okay if
you feel sick don't worry how do you
think I feel when you laugh at something
on our comedy symmetry please son if you
study today I will buy you clay
season four okay dad three hours later
I'm done
I like me too dad
this is torture the teacher had this up
today water h2o drink a lot of water
let's shake
glug-glug this is so totally me when I
drink a lot of water my water belly goes
black
please enter valid email address Viper
five four three two one zero
Yahoo yes confirm yes that is my email
legend legendary epic win I bet I can
get you to say red okay try it what
color is the sky blue told you I could
get you to say blue no you said red boom
my mind has been blown
he just got trolled I feel troll just
reading it I feel the same way
hey cat yeah can you walk like me
ahahahahaha yes not bad when I really
appreciate the framing of this meme
adding wind underneath with a knife
funny watermark that's how you know you
know you gonna have that your enemy and
it will automatically make it better
just win epic win dissolve egg shell off
with vinegar and it will become a naked
ed deck and found directions to
confusing ceiling fan oh yeah these
goddamn awful comments that always get
tough voted for some reason they're not
funny there's always some goddamn ass
let's never seen it before and they're
like ha that's funny
dick and ceiling fan all thumbs that up
stop you're part of the problem I'm sick
of it
what other comments like that big it's
some iPhone cookies to trick cops into
pulling me over then I just take a bite
and ask if cookies are against the law
dude that's Savage that is so freakin
Savage trolling the cops epic style
come on Jake hey man what's up just
converting oxygen into carbon dioxide
you know the usual WTF man school's out
why are you still doing science
breathing Jake I'm breathing you didn't
know carbon dioxide comes from your
[ __ ] you didn't know that you can
dumbass you didn't know salt would
sodium chloride you know salt would
sodium sulfur you dummy you can reason
want to have some fun go to Starbucks
okay this is a really cool trick guys I
think you'll enjoy this go to Starbucks
and order and when they ask the name get
this okay get this say trunk okay they
will be forced to yell out Trump and
everyone in the store will start crying
and I did it this morning and it was
awesome rolling lip tardes it's awesome
if you wanna have some fun go to
Starbucks and say I have an ar-15 if
anyone goes near the door I'm gonna
shoot it will be awesome I did it today
I'm losing it why do we see lightning
first and hear the sound after a couple
of seconds gaming Bible lag
I guess teachers don't know about Lange
that's when the game isn't running as
fast as it should be that's when your
processor is having an interconnection
bet you didn't know that stupid teacher
you're supposed to be a teacher that
teaches stuff but you don't even know
the game our metrics and rules Emma
Watson had to quit college because every
time she answered a question someone
said three points to Gryffindor trolling
level Gryffindor trolling level King
Gryffindor that's like top level that's
right about b-movie trolling or a genome
level trolling gary fiend or trolling
makes people quit school god damn me
Emma Watson that's why you dumb that's
why you have that dumbass face that's
why you're a feminist do you have a
girlfriend set yeah
dad nice where is she from from a
different nation or really which nation
my imagination trolling dance ethnic
style hey thanks for accepting my
request I like you be my girlfriend I'm
oh hey so you 89 patrons level over
ninety nine nine nine thousand it's over
it's over nine today's topic is
photosynthesis okay ma'am
so tell me what is photosynthesis
today's topic
give me sunglasses get full this is epic
do you know that's how these can meme
started this goddamn guy who even is he
who is he supposed to be just some guy
with a dumbass hair and hair and
sunglasses yeah why is Robert Downey jr.
there dentists in China be like let's
just put Robert Downey jr. in there you
know what let's put Robert Downey jr. in
every single goddamn meme that ever
existed alright if Donna Robert Downey
jr. is not an amine it's not it's not a
meme if there's not a meme and for the
record Robert Downey jr. it's not that
great okay everyone keeps holding him to
him as a standard of cool or badass
people really he's just a [ __ ] hack
okay that's right I'm the first one to
say it
he's cringy and he's not funny and he's
it's as if he's playing a character
outside he's goddamn Marvel bullsh is
that if I'm acting like PewDiePie
outside opieop I
[Music]
epic
did you see you just threw that
expensive watch away what a freaking
savage dude savage level Robert Downey
jr. this is actually a found object
okaying some scavenging of a folk art
buddy of mine and we run up working this
into a living art piece oh that was was
horse that's relay this is a Jaeger oh
you just made that up
like dude he just made that up on the
fly holy hell dude what an absolute
maniac who just makes [ __ ] up on the
flying like that like what how do you
even do that
trolling level Robert Downey jr. you
know what from now on Robert Downey jr.
is gonna be here in the video cuz I
think that will just make the video
better I don't know why you guys it's
cyber Brad actually do that like I want
him there it doesn't that make the video
better I think so
well nothing could make it this is even
worse oh by the way by btv guys by the
way by the way but the way do you know
that by the way you're gonna knuckles so
Savage what the hell was comedy in 20
2012 or 10 2015 like what furries are so
gay all they do is have sex we in weird
animal costumes ok well that looks kind
of cool I take back everything like a
fur dude
I'm referring out guys not because I
want to because I'm trolling lib tarts
epic style join me my fellow furries
damn mark a player's password be like
password my height error password too
short
get it originated a joke by octan racer
and robo jelly Trek don't steal this
joke or octan razor and robo jelly tech
are gonna come for you this video has
been sponsored by markiplier someone
give this guy an Oscar
yeah give him an Oscar I can't Ali
patrolling that's a brawl over this like
three people will get this but it's
worth it
pencil oh my god no one will understand
this joke
only three people in the world can you
imagine oh my gosh like what does a
pencil mean how was I gonna help him oh
my god oh I've seen this talk about a
what the heck moment let's get this
thing viral talk about a what the heck
moment why is it Cal doing that guys can
we get this viral can we get this video
viral can everyone tweet James Charles's
video and he will be like a total what
the heck moment if we can get this viral
by everyone tweeting James chalasis what
the heck that would be a total walk the
heck well I wish I could see his face
phone call home and a venturi why you
gotta call my mommy though middle school
man if that gives wrong number high
school
I don't give a beer I'll call my dad
[Applause]
can't tell if raises I'm just reading it
out okay oh dude gamers will understand
this mean if you're a gamer smash like
in this video just so I can know if you
and understand its mean or not I don't
get it
man eats steak in front of vegan on TV
crazy reaction savage someone give that
man an Oscar I've seen the thumbnail of
this but I've never actually seen the
video you're a vegan I'm really it's
really hard because I don't have I told
you I'm from Wisconsin okay and cheese
it was like one of my favorite things
see how that looks pretty good that's a
little rare medium rare yeah is this a
nice day I don't died cow hanging on
your fork is this bad that I'm eating
meat if you go hunting that's a totally
different story right the bloods on your
hands right now you're kind of just
enjoying the benefit and the Bloods on
someone else's hand
god I actually agree with the vegan but
the this happened with 2018 how did we
end up like this I wonder if there's
like a PD PI one yeah don't be racist be
like beautify he's Swedish speaks
English they think Italian girlfriend
and acts don't be racist be PewDiePie
guys the least racist person on the
goddamn planet
OOP oh my god it's Robert Downey jr.
trolling level Tony Stark how's it going
Tony I have this headache that comes and
goes Steve walks in hi Tony
there it is again Tony's freaking stark
is so genetic thumbs up this video for
Tony Stark thank you guys
finally we have proved that main review
isn't really the place where memes goes
to die actually you're right god damn it
actually it's wherever Tony Stark is
okay you want pyramids we got him oh
you're into castles huh we got you
covered baby you want some bets easy we
got it all this game is still relevant
god damn it